so the nice thing about Venus is if
there's a giant living civilization
there it'll be airborne so you can just
fly through and collect samples yeah
with Mars and uh moons of uh Saturn
Jupiter you're gonna have to dig
under to find the civilizations right
dead or living right and so yeah maybe
it's easier than for Venus because
suddenly you can imagine just a balloon
floating through the atmosphere
um the or a drone or something that
would have the capability of just
scooping up and sampling
um to dig into the surface of Mars is
maybe
feasible-ish with you know especially
with something like Starship that could
launch you know a huge Digger basically
to the surface and you could just
excavate away at the surface but for
something like Europa
um we really are still unclear about how
thick the ice layer is how you would
melt through that huge thick layer to
get to the ocean and then potentially
also discussions about contamination the
problem with looking for life in the
solar system which is different from
looking for life with exoplanets is that
you always run the risk of especially if
you visit there of introducing the life
yourself
right it's very difficult to completely
exterminate every single microbe and
Spore on the surface of your of your
Rover or the surface of your Lander and
so there's always a risk of introducing
something I mean
to some extent there is continuous
exchange of material between these
plants naturally on top of that as well
and now we're sort of accelerating that
process to some degree
um and so if you dig into europa's
surface which probably is completely
pristine it's very unlikely there has
been much exchange with the outside
world for its subsurface ocean
You Are For the First Time potentially
introducing bacterial spores into that
environment that may compete or may
introduce spurious signatures for the
life you're looking for and so
it's it's almost an ethical question as
to how to proceed with looking for life
on those subsurface oceans and I don't
think one we've really
have a good resolution for at this point
ethical assuming ethical in terms of
concern
for the
the like for preserving life elsewhere
not like not to murder it as opposed to
Scientific one I mean we always worry
about a space virus right coming coming
here or you know some kind of external
source and we would be the source of
that potential contamination or the
other direction yeah I mean
they that you know the whatever whatever
survives in such harsh conditions might
be pretty good at uh
surviving in all conditions it might be
a little bit more resilient and robust
so I might actually take a ride on us
back home possibly I mean I'm sure I'm
sure that some people will be concerned
about that I think we would we would
hopefully have some containment uh
procedures as if we did sample return or
you mean you don't even really need a
sample return these days you can pretty
much sound like a little micro
laboratory to the other planet to deal
with experiments you know in situ and
then just send them back to your planet
the data and so I don't think this is
necessary that especially for a case
like that where you might have
contamination concerns that you have to
bring samples back
um although probably if you brought back
European Sushi it would probably sell
for quite a bit with the billionaires in
New York City
Sushi yeah
um I would love from an engineering
perspective just to see all the
different candidates and designs for
like the scooper for Venus and the
scooper for Europa and and Mars I
haven't really look deeply into how they
actually like the actual engineering of
collecting samples because that's the
engineering of that
is probably essential for not either
destroying life or or polluting it with
our own microbes and so on so that's an
interesting engineering challenge I
usually for Rovers and stuff focus on
the on the robot on the
sort of the mobility aspect of it on the
robotics the perception and the movement
and the planning and the control but
there's probably the scooper is probably
where the action is yeah the microscopic
sample collection so basically you have
to first clean
your vehicle make sure it doesn't have
any Earth-like things on it and then you
have to put it into some kind of thing
that's perfectly sealed from the
environment so if we bring it back or we
analyze it it's not
um it's not going to bring anything else
uh external and yeah I don't know it
could be that would be an interesting
engineering design there yeah I mean
Curiosity has been uh leaving these
little pods on the surface quite
recently there's some neat photos you
can find online and it's they kind of
look like a lightsaber hilts which so
um that yeah to me I think I tweeted
something like uh you know this weapon
is your life like don't lose it
curiosity because it's just dumping
these little vials everywhere and it's
yeah it is scooping up these things and
the intention is that in the future
um there will be a sample return mission
that will come and pick these up
um but it's I mean the engineering
behind those things is so impressive the
thing that blows me away the most has
been The Landings
um especially I'm trained to be a pilot
at the moment so that's the sort of you
know watching Landings has become like
my I'll be on YouTube at the moment and
how not to do it how to do it with
different levels of conditions and
things but with the you know when we
think about landing on Mars Just the
light travel time effect means that
there's no possibility of a human
controlling that descent and so you have
to put all of your faith and your trust
in the computer code or the AI or
whatever it is that you've put on board
that thing to to make the correct
descent
um and so there's this famous uh period
called seven minutes of hell where
you're basically waiting for that light
travel time to come back to know whether
you're vehicle successfully landed on
the surface or not and during that
period you know in your mind
simultaneously that it is doing these
multi-stages of
um deploying its parachute deploying the
crane
activating its Jets to come down and
controlling its descent to the surface
and then the crane has to fly away so it
doesn't accidentally hit the Rover and
so there's a series of multi-stage
points where any any of them go wrong
you know the whole mission could could
go awry
um and so the fact that we are fairly
consistently able to build these
machines that can do this autonomously
is to me one of the most impressive acts
of engineering that NASA have achieved